that's not just a golf like the GTI
sitting behind me it's the entire family
of golf's and you can buy I think five
different variants here in the US let me
start with you Michael and ask you what
this what this award means to you
because this is a car that's been around
for 40 years yes and it's definitely at
the heart in the heart of the brain fox
logging it's the DNA of Volkswagen and
we're excited and extremely proud to be
honest you know you mentioned this and
it's by its four models it's the TSI gas
motors the TDI clean diesel model the
GTI sporting water and now also the fuel
I mean the one hundred percent
all-electric ego and and for us it's
it's it's a great honor you know and I
think we deserved it as well but on the
other hand it really speaks to what we
do now in the United States you and
that's great so I mean motor trends Car
of the Year probably has holds the most
cachet of any of the auto mags here in
the US why choose the golf when it's
been around for so long it's ubiquitous
it's I don't say the common choice but
it's kind of the common sense choice
well obviously when you're buying a car
sure sure you know there's a ton of new
vehicles that come out every year our
award is given to only the all-new or
substantially upgraded models there were
23 in contention this year and you know
from the start we looked at it and this
is really if you're a car guy you have
to respect what's going on here with the
golf I mean it the packaging wise its
small footprint but but really enormous
on the inside the original hot hatch yet
it does give you some of that big car
feel on the road it's quiet it's smooth
and then you know as Michael mentioned
there's really a flavor of golf for
whatever your need or want is you have
GTI friend of sporty cars you're you
know if your fuel efficiency you get TDI
or an eagle all-electric never have to
go to the pump and then the value play
the volume so the TSI phenomenal vehicle
so you don't cross the board against our
award criteria killed it how do you how
do you differentiate I mean I'm
generation golf so I grew up with these
cars but this is the seventh iteration
what makes mark seven different from
mark sick
well all the flexibility of the new
platform we split on the latest platform
for the for the compact cars in the new
Volkswagen Group and therefore it's a
great basis for all the different
technologies we just talked about and
you know and as ed mentioned you know
the car is even a little bit smaller but
it's much more spacious interior and
internally because we extended the
wheelbase for instance and it's it's
less weight so it's better it has more
fuel economy and and so we substantially
further develop the car and made it much
much better and i think this you know to
win this award here in the US with the
segment which is not that large compared
to mid-size sedans for instance is not
just a great honor but it's it's it's
great feedback next to all the
competitors which have lost and yes very
tactfully put some of them you are your
own are built on the same platform right
i mean the 83 i saw was in the running
as well it's built on the same platform
as the golf but there were some strong
competitors the new Mustang has made
some real steps forward afford the new
the BMW 235 is a big favorite of auto
journalists I mean how tough is it to
make this decision how much fighting is
there in the Motor Trend boardroom you
know the the finalists were all very
competitive you mentioned your mustang
with a huge you know independent rear
suspension has a new you know ecoboost
four-cylinder you know BMW fantastic
driving vehicle that the platform 8 a-3
we looked at them head-to-head and said
you know there's all of these great
features that they share but the value
play is here you know you can get an A
three and you can get everything that's
here but why would you when this is such
a great car at a much lower price point
so that must make your meeting with
scott Keogh uncomfortable next week in
LA right i mean what do you say to the
guys at audi know when when you say oh
we make the better car on the same
platform no Scott and I are great
colleagues you know and I think he's
appreciating this and for me it's not
the better with Audi it's it's it's it's
more you know if you look at it as an
American icon like the Mustang for
instance or like also at the BMW and
that we all perform these cars this is
the key message here and and then this
is very encouraging because you know
after we've brought the car here to the
market it shows that we are
direction back here and that we sell
more cars and our dealers are more happy
and then so that's the positive news